banner mon jeu
et quelle mouche a piqué pamela anderson
hier la star d' alerte à malibu a poussé
un violent coup de gueule sur twitter
contre les émissions de télé-réalité
elle explique le parc à ne pas garder de
bons souvenirs de ses participations
dans les émissions de télé réalité ce
que j'aimais faire de la télé réalité
s'il vous plaît arrêtez avec ces
émissions où ces stars de la réalité
voilà où ces stars de la télé réalité
même la france en est pollué c'est une
épidémie de laideur de compétition
superficiel et désespéré qui exploite
les artistes elle s'en est prise ensuite
aux agents de célébrités qui les force à
participer à ces émissions car c'est
très bien payé et que les agents
touchent une importante commission est
liée au final vous retrouvez sans avoir
gagné ni joie ni vraiment beaucoup
d'argent vous sentez utiliser salle et
sans aucun sentiment d'accomplissement
alors c'est vrai que pamela anderson
souvenez vous elle était la marraine des
anges de la télé-réalité 2 sur nrj12 à
l'aller même rendu visite aux anges dans
la villa de miami
regardez c'est en 2011 et juste après je
vous vous allez me dire si vous zappez
ou si vous matez j'ai des extraits de
ouf et on vous a fait le top 3 des
meilleurs extraits de télé réalité
regardez c'est parti regardez pamela
[Musique]
quand j'ai ouvert la porte et que j'ai
vu pas mal âge halluciné jeu
moi je suis resté mais sur le cul quand
l'hymne
c'est dire
alors
j'imaginais retouchée mais non elle est
vraiment allé vraiment trop belle alors
est ce que vous savez où est ce que ma
[Applaudissements]
télé réalité comme on aime ce qu'aiment
les téléspectateurs c'est les perles des
candidats alors est-ce qu'elles sont
donnés est ce que sont écrites à
l'avancé ils nous répondent matthieu
delormeau vous connaissez très bien ça
et bien sûr benjamin castaldi des
petites phrases qui reviennent souvent
pas le temps
regardez à quoi servent ils à nos
oreilles du chien comme ça on repère la
chine son satellite j'ai vécu là la
troisième guerre mondiale schumaker là
c'est moi un animal à cornes 1,4 et caro
s'appelle m2 province donc ça se trouve
qu'en province que le célèbre temps le
11 novembre la fête de la musique mais
c'est pas georges einstein
c'est george washington geagea aurélie
et samir rentrer dans la maison
et là c'est la guerre mondiale de 78 au
kilomètre il n'y a pas si longtemps que
ça je pensais que la guadeloupe était à
côté de la corse basque à la météo tu as
vu quand il présente la carte de la
france et met la guadeloupe à côté de la
corse
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eue envers l'ex vous mater oui je
sais vous envie de ça va parce que je
vous le dis le classement des
téléréalités en ce moment vous le savez
il ya les anges de la télé-réalité
d'aller marseillais la villa des coeurs
brisés troisième position c'est les
anges qui marchent pas bien 240 humilité
les spectacles ni la villa des coeurs
brisés 350 mille téléspectateurs et les
marseillais sont les leaders 748 1000
téléspectateurs pour les marseillais qui
sont en tête alors oui je ne suis pas de
ceux qui crachent sur la téléréalité der
l'imam comme les marseillais j'aime bien
il ya des téléspectateurs je ne les
méprise pas du tout ça distrait
c'est parfois émouvant il ya des
personnages comme paga dans les
marseillais n'ont ses vrais gens mais
oui moi aussi
et donc je trouve que se dire comme ça
je zappe d'un seul coup c'est être un
peu comme un intellectuel évoqué le
voilà alors oui mathieu vous matez aussi
à l'en avant
vous avez mis à profit maximal déjà à
l'accord passé quoi le premier coup de
gueule c'est pamela anderson la vision
de cannes a dit le béa tout petit truc
sur les orges 2e j étais on ait le droit
à 35 minutes montre en main de pamela
anderson a écoute toi c est la redeem
ares 1 x combien du bar dit gbagbo a dit
oui tous dit oui c'est ça n était pas du
tout cent mille balles cent mille euros
1 et nous forcément ça a été en soit
1000 euros mais pardon pardon mes joies
du ramier tous âges de la dorna
mais ça a été après sur plein d'épisodes
parce qu'il fallait retirer sur plein
d'épisodes
enfin il est resté 30 minutes elle a dit
bonjour nous on a fait plein de leur
droit de chasse quelle forme il aurait
alors derrière j'ai pas bien compris ça
je me sens pas accompli rendent pognon
c'est trente minutes albanel elle parle
des gens qui sont dedans mais enfin côté
la télé en lieu c'est la première chose
que je voulais dire alors ce qu'on aime
aussi si les fautes de français et
gilles comme moody's sur ce que vous
avez mal à votre france que vous voyez
toutes les fautes de français que vous
allez voir car fois oui honnêtement
faire là c'est vrai
les yeux je suis super surprise ma moi
désolé j'ai passé mon sport et le salut
est l âge que je peux avoir c'est ce
ponton aujourd'hui ils sont venus à la
boxe en fait pour nous bisouter du coup
bah moi je me rapproche et je fais mon
espionnage
je les connais bon se mettre sur leur
trente neuf habitat long been pire est
toujours pas recommencé un contrat ça y
est je sens qu'il ya une anguille sous
le rocher
[Applaudissements]